[MUSIC]
I want to take you back to the year 2010,
it's my senior year of high school and
I'm in the final round of
a speech team tournament.
Yes, I was the nerd in high school who
did speech he considered it a sport.
[LAUGH]
>> There are five of the finalists in
the room, 30 people there to watch us and
three judges sitting in the front row with
their pens and
evaluation forms ready to go.
And I'm there to give an eight
minute speech on racial diversity.
So I deliver my speech,
listened to my competitors do the same,
gave them a cute little bit
of applause and a fake smile.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
then we all headed to the auditorium
to hear the final results, and
in first place, they announced,
Shawan Jackson.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Of course I share that story because I
want you to know how fabulous I am.
>> [LAUGH] But
really I share that story because
it was a moment of pride back then.
But when I look back on that moment today,
I'm not met with pride,
I actually feel regret.
What I didn't mention at the beginning
of my talk is that, that speech
wasn't advocating for racial diversity,
I essentially argued against it.
To be fair,
I didn't say that diversity itself is bad,
I just didn't understand the merits
of racial diversity in particular.
In large part because I didn't understand
the full extent of racial inequity.
Reflecting on this moment, I realized that
while I had strong communication skills
back then,
I lacked critical consciousness.
A term coined by Paulo Freire, a Brazilian
philosopher that speaks to one's
ability to critically examine the world
and do something to change it.
Realizing this inspired me to help other
youth, especially underserved youth,
build not just their communication skills,
but also their critical consciousness.
With the hope that they'll be able to
speak persuasively about social justice.
But in doing this work,
I've realized that critical consciousness
isn't just about challenging what you say,
it's also about challenging how you
present yourself and your ideas.
Now when I first started teaching public
speaking, I did not realize this,
I used to teach my students
the control framework.
It went a little something like this,
control your body stand up straight, relax
your shoulders, make sure they're in line
with your feet gesture, but not too much.
Control your voice, speak up,
pace yourself pause so that people really
listen, okay, not that long-
>> [LAUGH]
>> And enunciate every single word as you
speak.
Now research shows that if
you do those behaviors,
you actually do sound more persuasive.
But the more I've been working
with youth of color, and
the more I've been reflecting
on my own public speaking style,
I realized that there's a point
when control becomes conformity,
when the right way to speak
becomes the white way to do it.
Now let me be clear I don't dislike the
way that white people speak, I love y'all.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But
it saddens me that we have this
unstated expectation that,
to be heard you have to make yourself
palatable to white majority culture.
Maybe that means cutting out the black
vernacular you learned at home because
it's not professional.
Or maybe that means limiting your
expressions because you were told you need
to tone it down.
Or maybe it's cutting your Afro,
like I did in the eighth grade,
because you learn that
it's not presentable.
These behaviors reflect the concept
called respectability politics,
when marginalized people present
themselves in ways that are pleasing or
respectable to those with more privilege.
On the one hand, this makes
complete sense, our world favors
those who just fit in, and
as important as authenticity is,
it comes with a risk of being judged,
of being ignored, of being silenced.
And this is a risk that many people
care about, not just people of color.
According to a 2014 inclusion report
from Deloitte, 83% of lesbian,
gay and bisexual people in the US,
said they're not fully themselves at work.
66% of woman said the same, and
so did 44% of straight White men.
Many of us feel this pressure to conform,
to avoid the risk of exclusion,
but conformity comes with a cost.
Every time we change how we present,
from the words we use to our tone to our
presentation, we validate the status quo
that is not equally appreciate
multiple forms of presentation.
We send a message to younger
generations that you can be heard, so
long as you sound look and
dress more or less, like everyone else.
The easy answer would be what don't
conform when you communicate,
but it's not that straightforward.
Because at times you do need to
accommodate your audience, so
that you can make your perspective heard.
I don't know the answer to this question
of how to deal with that, on the one hand,
I do want to be authentic,
on the other hand, I want to be heard.
Even as I'm standing here
in front of you right now,
I'm wondering if the way I'm dressed and
the way I'm presenting is really me or
just what I think you want me to be.
And if I can't answer that question for
myself,
who am I to talk to my students about it?
One of my mentors said, you don't need
to have the perfect answer, Shawan.
Just open up the conversation
with your students, so
they can critically engage with the topic.
So now in one of my classes
on public speaking,
I read a series of statements and
ask students go to one side if you agree,
another side of you disagree and somewhere
in the middle if you're conflicted.
Agree or disagree, if I were giving
a speech in front of politicians,
I would change my hair so
that I look more professional.
Students spread out across the entire
room and began to debate their opinions.
One of my Latino student said,
I'm not going to straighten my curly
because that's a part of who I am.
Another student respectfully disagrees and
says,
it's not that big of a deal to me,
so I'm going to do it,
we don't come to a perfect answer in
that activity, but that's not the goal.
The goal is simply to question
whether persuasion can be problematic.
In the same activity I read another
statement, agree or disagree,
to make people care about a social issue,
I will share a sad story about myself.
This leads to a critical
conversation about storytelling,
too often we share those sad stories so
that people feel bad for us.
And while those stories can be moving,
they can often fall into this trap of
poverty porn, you know what that is.
Those TV ads about those poor little
kids in Africa who need your donation,
that story about a boy named Tony, who
grew up in Chicago in a rundown apartment
in a single parent home who
will not make it in life,
unless you donate to his nonprofit.
That's poverty porn.
Storytelling is a powerful tool of
persuasion, but the problem with poverty
porn is that, it reduces your humanities
to the struggles you've endured.
Without critically examining the
narratives we're putting forward, we risk
diluting our self-worth, presenting an
incomplete picture of who we really are.
And that's a problem, when I was
teaching public speaking last summer,
I had a student who I won't soon forget,
Jose.
He's a junior now,
Dominican American incredibly smart,
and he ditched about half of my classes.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So one day, I'm in the hallway with
him and I take them to the side,
just to say what's going on.
He told me he didn't like public speaking,
I figured just about as much, but
his reason why is what really got to me.
It doesn't matter how
much we speak up he said,
at the end of the day, rich,
white people will always be in power.
Deep down I fear that Jose is right,
not because rich,
white people will literally always be
in power, but because if we're not
mindful of how we're presenting,
how we're advocating for change,
we risk changing the people in power, but
leaving the culture largely the same.
So if I were talking to younger Shawan
today, I would tell them two things one,
you're going to have that baby face for
the next 10 years, at least, I'm sorry.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It is what it is.
>> And two and more importantly,
I would say that it's not
enough to change your topic for
that speech team competition, to argue for
racial diversity instead of against it.
You also need to critically question how
you're presenting yourself in that room,
are you making yourself
conforming too much?
How far are you willing to go?
And I want Shawan to think about those
questions as a teenager because ten
years later I want him to feel free and
comfortable to speak his own truth.
The entire truth, not just because
it will make me feel better, but
because when you speak your truth,
your whole truth,
you empower everyone else around
you to do the same, thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]